اذا الوثائق السريه التي اكتشفت صدفه باحد
مكاتب بيدن حين كان نائبا لاوما استدعت
المزيد من عمليات التفتيش البحث الاولي
كشف حزمه جديده سريه كذلك في مكان منفصل
عن مكتب واشنطن الذي استخدمه بايضا بعد
مغادره اداراته ومغادره اداره اوباما طبعا
مساعد الرئيس الامريكي اكتشفوا هذه
المجموعه خلال بحث وصف بالشامل في مواقع
اخرى استخدامها الرئيس ووفقا لشبكه ام بي
سي نيوز الامريكيه لم يتضح على الفور
مستوى تصنيف الوثائق الاضافيه وعددها
وموقعها الدقيق كما لم يتضح تاريخ
اكتشافها او عدد ممتلكات بيدن التي فتشت
وما اذا كان البحث عن مواد سريه اخرى قد
اكتمل باي ضمن فوجئ بالوثائق المكتشفه
واكد عدم معرفته بما هو موجود داخل هذه
الوثائق حسب قوله في صدمه حدثون باسمي
وزاره العدل و مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي
والبيت الابيض التعليق على هذا الامر
اختلاف رئيسي بين قضيتين ترامب وبعيدن
يركز عليه اعلام امريكي مع استبعاد تحول
وثائق الاخير لمساله جنائيه مماثله لبيضن
واشنطن بوست لا فتاه الى تعاون محامي بيدن
مع وزاره العدل وتسليم الوثائق توعيه
وبسرعه لاداره المحفوظات الوطنيه وهو
مشاهدينا على عكس ما وصف بعرقله تراب
لجهود السعاده
وستعلق وزاره العدل بعد قليل على هذه
الوثائق تكون معنا
[موسيقى]